tu es enfant
je ne sais pas mais elle a des goûts
elle n'a personne d'autre
nous ne sommes pas des bêtes sauvages
les singes se battent pour survivre
migeon humain du sein tous morts
maintenant longtemps très longtemps de
méchants humains soldats
un jour vos enfants vous demanderont
est ce que tu as fait pendant la plus
grande guerre vous pourrez leur répondre
j'ai combattu pour défendre secondes
nous l'avons créée dès maintenant
nous allons en finir avec ces
monstruosités
pas de pitié pas de pair
c'est la guerre
ensemble singes fort
vous êtes impressionnant
très intelligent
[Musique]
plus fort que nous mais vous faites de
tout ça une affaire beaucoup trop
personnel vous partez au quart de tour
je n'ai pas commencé cette caire
mais je la termine